the Sony and Disney spider-man deal has
taken up so much of our time and
attention over the past few weeks that
we've forgotten about some major
exciting news coming up and one of those
exciting things is venom venom 2 is
going to start filming soon what's up
everyone it's Warren and we have some
major venom news today the last time we
left Eddie Brock and venom they were
talking to a person by the name of
Cletus Kasady in a prison cell now of
course if you are a true venom fan you
know that Cletus Kasady is the one and
only carnage and although Cletus did not
have the red symbiote yet in the
post-credits scene of venom he did drop
the bomb he told Eddie that when he gets
out there's going to be carnage
so venom 2 is set up for carnage to
appear but with the Disney Sony deal
falling through is spider-man going to
appear as well I'll talk about some new
information that we have learned about
venom 2 in this video but first I'm
giving away an Xbox one or a ps4 at
500,000 subscribers so be sure to
subscribe to my channel to enter my
giveaway and I've teamed up with Kaos to
give away a Nintendo switch so be sure
to check out the link in the description
down below so you can enter that
giveaway as well so as I mentioned Sony
Pictures venom 2 is going to start
production very soon in fact a couple of
days ago discussing film has revealed
that Sony's venom 2 is going to start
production on November 18th
and yesterday thanks to an exclusive by
HN entertainment they have confirmed
that filming will take place at Warner
Brothers Studios Leavesden which is
located in Watford England now the real
interesting thing about this news is
that this studio is where they shot
spider-man far from home and is right
down the street from Tom Hollands house
so this obviously raises the question is
Tom Hollands spider-man going to be in
venom too is he going to team up with
venom to fight carnage or are him and
venom going to go at it because although
the post-credits scene of venom did set
up carnage to come in the next movie
given everything that has happened
between Sony and Disney perhaps carnage
is going to be put on the back burner
for venom 3 and they're going to bring
spider-man into venom 2 now the studio's
location may not have anything to do
with it at all but this is obviously a
really really big question that
everybody has been thinking about lately
a few days ago the CEO for Sony
officially released a statement saying
that for the moment the door is closed
with the deal with Disney so as of right
now Tom Hollands spider-man is not in
the MCU and Sony is free to use him in a
venom film if they would like to and to
top it all off we learned earlier this
week that Sony does want to put
spider-man in a venom movie we learned
that Tom Holland actually shot a cameo
for the very first Vin a movie but
Marvel asked them to take him out Marvel
and Disney did not want people to think
that venom was a part of the MCU and
they thought that spider-man appearing
in a venom movie may confuse people and
make them think that venom is in the MCU
so sony has already tried to put Tom
Hollands spider-man in venom but Marvel
and Disney said no however Marvel and
Disney are no longer in the picture that
means that Sony can do whatever they
want with spider-man and everybody
including Sony has been waiting for a
spider-man venom crossover so could we
be seen spider-man and venom go at it
and then go on to take on carnage down
the road it wouldn't really be hard to
introduce Peter Parker in a venom movie
Eddie Brock is a reporter and Peter
Parker has just had his identity
revealed the whole world now knows that
Peter Parker is spider-man
and thanks to Mysterio they all think
that he is a murderer definitely sounds
like a story that Eddie Brock could get
on top of and if he gets mad enough he
could even use venom to try and take him
down
so what could end up happening is that
Eddie Brock eventually finds Peter
Parker venom and spider-man go at it but
then Eddie realizes that Peter is good
this could also be a really good way to
clear Peter Parker's name Eddie is now a
respected reporter after the events of
venom and could help clear Peters name
by exposing what Mysterio really did so
production for venom 2 is going to start
on November 18th it's going to be at
Warner Brothers Studios Leavesden in
Watford England and this news was
announced right after Sony said that for
the moment the deal is done
with Disney so could we see spider-man
in venom 2 right now it's looking like
that is a major possibility and if
spider-man is out of the MCU this is the
next best thing so let me know down
below in the comments if you want to see
venom go up against spider-man in venom
to and again don't forget to subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
for your chance to win in Xbox one or a
ps4 and if you'd like a chance to win a
Nintendo switch be sure to click the
link in the description down below to go
to the giveaway website as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof